now talking about today's session
precision medicine is changing the way
we understand
diagnose and treat major
life-threatening diseases
and this transformation is driven by
high throughput molecular data
that is being collected from patients
animal models
and large-scale cell line experiments
and in this program bioinformatics for
precision medicine
we would explore how the various omics
data types generated in these studies
can be analyzed and integrated to study
the basic biology associated with the
viruses
and their hosts cancer onset and the
development
and outcomes as well my name is sunalika
ray
and i'm the omixlogic community manager
and i'm responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are part of a bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech so before we
start with today's session i would want
to introduce us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use accessible tools
and our mission is to make
bioinformatics more accessible
our mixed logic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration
between pine biotech and numerous
academic institutions that have
participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design omics logic
is an international program that is
currently running
in five different regions with over 10
000 users around the world
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local
and reshare coordinators that are
helping refine local program logistics
and leverage our online training
resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
this online program includes weekly
sessions with an instructor
online tracking and review of student
progress
access to all the resources and
materials online for
self-paced learning access to expert
guidance and problem solving
educational and research pipelines and
domain data analysis
on our big data server let me introduce
you to the program
mentors we have dr harpreet with us
she has an expertise in the application
of statistical machine learning
techniques
on biomedical data and the development
of prediction tools and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
dr mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
and over the past several years he has
been developing collaborations with
universities
as a mentor and project lead for homage
logic training and research fellowship
and dr japoniano chevas he is a
post-doctoral fellow at university of
chicago
he is killed in bioinformatics and is an
expert in glioblastoma
now i would want to invite elia brodsky
ceo pine biotech to discuss further
about the session over to eugenia
thank you very much and great to have
all of you here
today so today we'll
talk about our first session uh for
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and i want to begin with a brief
introduction to
what precision medicine is so maybe i
can ask that question to all of you
again thank you for joining i would like
to ask
all of you i'm sure that many of you
have the background and the expertise
and the interest in precision medicine
how would you define precision medicine
so if you could
use the chat to type in your answers i
would love to know what you think
so what is the definition of precision
medicine
hello hello yes hello
yeah a medicine which
cured the patient with minimal side
effects
okay excellent thank you uh
praveen anushka mentioned that this is a
method of disease
treatment uh saran is mentioning that
personalized medicine based on
pharmacogenomics
excellent enzyme asp
is saying that this is the use of tools
and approaches
in a more personalized way all right
excellent so
great answers everyone and i think that
we can
turn to a formal definition
of what is personalized medicine and
what is precision medicine because
there's actually a distinction between
the two
okay excellent someone else is adding
here chiang mai is saying medicines
engineered to specific genotypes as to
enhance
efficacy uh gerald
medical solutions specific to the
genetic characteristics of an individual
all right vinay is saying customized
drug to each individual
so excellent answers let me read out the
formal definition
so precision medicine is an emerging
approach for disease treatment and
prevention
that takes into account individual
variable
gene environment and lifestyle
for each person this approach will allow
doctors and researchers to predict
more accurately which treatment and
prevention strategies for a particular
disease
will work in which groups of people it
is
in contrast to a one-size-fit-all
approach
in which disease treatment and
prevention strategies are developed for
the average person
with less consideration for the
differences between individuals
so as you can see the personalized and
the
precision part of it are actually
intertwined and what's important is that
after decades of research
we now know that the detailed genetic
and other molecular information about a
patient's condition
can be and should be used to deploy
effective patient-specific remedies
unfortunately the overall statement
that we are describing here is very
um much a broad statement that
lacks certain details and those details
is what we want to
focus on in this program but this is a
good point for us to start this
discussion because
ultimately we mentioned the genotyping
so we
mentioned genes and specific genomic
information
we mentioned lifestyle and other types
of
variable factors that can affect the
treatment efficacy
or outcome and can also help us detect
disease early so we'll talk about these
aspects as well
and importantly what combines
all of these factors is that these
factors come from data
so today this data is superficial
based on symptoms that are categorized
with
clinical broad terms and we are moving
towards a more precise division of these
terms
using molecular phenotypes and molecular
data
so before we continue speaking about
precision medicine
briefly about myself and about our
company
we are a technology transfer company the
company originated at the university of
haifa in israel
and the company co-founders dr alfred
tauber and dr lena brodsky
combined the vision for precision
medicine and
the significant role that bioinformatics
plays
in precision medicine where the need to
integrate
multi-omics data is a very important
part and a cutting edge of research that
is of interest to many different
clintons
as well as researchers around the world
but this
research effort has been taken into a
broader
to the broader audience by our team our
team includes
people that work on curriculum design
that help
design delivery methods to make this
content available online it also
includes programmers and
bioinformaticians that are skilled
in analysis of various types of data and
overall
our mission is to make data science
available for a broader audience
so the overall theme of the omixlogic
programs
is that we are focused on biology as a
data science
developing applications of high
throughput data analysis
to allow participants of
all backgrounds to utilize them and
solve
the need for data literacy in
application to biomedical
challenges and so here you can see some
areas including
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience
as well as agriculture so to address
this challenge we actually have designed
kind of the three pillars of what our
programs are all about so the goal of
onyx logic is to provide training
in bioinformatics guided by mentors and
pure example
we want to grow a community that shares
a passion for data-driven research
in an appreciation for citizen science
and we want to help
students clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in the life of data science
and so we have been working on enabling
research using these three things
big data analysis tools that are easy to
use and train people to use them
effectively
provide mentorship by building a network
of mentors that are available
for answering your questions and guiding
your research
and then providing training and so this
program is one of the examples of
a training program that is designed to
provide you with very specific learning
outcomes and briefly i will mention also
how we will achieve that
for those of you that are joining this
program so one of the outcomes that is
very important in this
precision medicine topic is the basic
understanding of scientific literature
that describes analysis of omics data
through the lens of precision medicine
we will go through
project examples and literature that
will help you understand this topic
not from me but from experts that have
spent
years researching these topics and
together we will learn
how they have applied bioinformatics
methods effectively
to extract meaningful and translational
ideas
that are applicable in the clinical
sense
we will also focus on basic processing
steps for next generation sequencing
data analysis
with consistent accuracy so
independently you can conduct such
analysis
we will perform exploratory analysis and
generate a hypothesis from data or
data-driven research we'll focus on that
and you will be able to think about the
different categories
and factors in your data to design
contrasts for statistical tests
and prepare data for machine learning
you will also be able to
annotate found signal using biological
databases and references
identify appropriate data sets for
answering a biological question
plan your bioinformatics analysis from
start to finish independently
and present a project proposal including
the rationale the methods
scientific background and anticipated
results so these are really
the objectives for this program in the
context of
precision medicine or how does
bioinformatics
play a role in precision medicine and to
help us with all of this we have
this network of mentors that will be
accessible throughout the summer
i will briefly we will briefly introduce
each one of them throughout the next
several programs that we have and the
summer training
programs are designed to actually lead
to a research project and for those of
you that are considering this path
we have multiple programs available that
precision medicine source cove 2 data
analysis
we have programs on data science focused
on technical skills like coding and
machine learning
and we also have a research fellowship
program and the research fellowship
program
is a special opportunity that provides
you with
hands-on support and a research
focused group of people that can plan
and actually execute the analysis that
they're planning
and develop a research project in a
short time
now for all of you that are already a
part of the research fellowship or are
planning to find
a research fellowship that fits your
needs we welcome you to first join a
training program like this one
and then in the future as you might be
interested to work
more on a research project you can join
the research fellowship
for those that are working already on
project or and would like to join
a research symposium in august august
21st to 22nd we will have
a specially designed omics research
symposium that is organized with our
partners
at the louisiana biomedical research
network georgetown university
university of haifa and many others that
will provide you with an opportunity to
highlight your achievement through a
poster session and presentation of your
project
prizes and also to learn about
cutting-edge research and applications
of bioinformatics
undergraduate masters and phd programs
in bioinformatics including for
international students we will offer
also a glimpse of what the recruiters
and industry
are looking for in those that are
willing to apply
for a position how do you get into an
internship or how do you identify job
opportunities
if you have been trained in
bioinformatics and
also we will discuss some effective
resources for training in education
and bioinformatics and data science and
obviously there will be prizes for the
best
high school college and citizen science
research project so
we're excited and we're looking forward
towards this and all of you that are
joining this session if you're a part of
our training programs or not
you are welcome to join and we will be
sending out
information on this soon
so now let me turn to bioinformatics for
precision medicine so this is our first
session
and in today's session we will talk
about translational bioinformatics
approaches that
lead to effective outcomes
and help address the gaps in precision
medicine
and uh let's start by talking a little
bit about the future of medicine so what
is the future of medicine and where
are we to actually facilitate some
progress in this so i think that it is
obvious that to make these better
decisions about patients
and treatments and outcomes there has to
be
aggregation of data and there has to be
an integration between lab data research
data
and data coming from the patients and
all of this data has to be presented to
experts that understand the data in such
a way that they can
discuss the results of analysis in a
meaningful way
and they can translate this information
to practical decisions that they have to
make
leading to an effective identification
of
areas of research that then could be
addressed
by pharmaceutical companies
biotechnology companies
and others that are involved in
addressing the unmet needs
and so what we see this is as
a combination of personal and precise
and there has to be a number of
components that come together to make
that possible
so beyond the general statements like we
have
discussed up until now let's talk about
how does this actually play out
in different examples so most people
would agree that we can separate divide
the diseases into two kinds
infectious diseases and non-infectious
diseases so infectious diseases
are spread directly or indirectly from
one person to another
caused by pathogenic microorganisms such
as bacteria viruses parasites or fungi
and non-infectious diseases are not
caused by a pathogen
and cannot be shared from one person to
another they're caused by
environments nutritional deficiencies
lifestyle choices
and genetic inheritance and so to
study these diseases we can leverage
data that is widely available
and what i wanted to do today is take a
look at some of these examples
to kind of identify what types of data
and what types of analysis
is appropriate for each type of data so
that we have a sense of what might be
the source of
information and the application of the
information that we derive
from such data so omix data in
infectious disease research can include
viral genomics and evolution and we all
know that this is a very
relevant topic today as we are in the
middle of a pandemic and actually
not just this pandemic but we live in an
era
of series of epidemics starting from
stars one
flu as you remember bird flu ebola virus
outbreaks
rhinovirus is now again reappearing so
we live in an era of
epidemics and pandemics and
understanding the pathogens that cause
this in a precise way
is a component of precision medicine
or precision public health we also
understand now
different drivers of infection and
responses and those include our micro
environment
including the microbiome and immune
responses
and markers of the immune responses that
we can detect in patients
and ultimately when we speak about
infectious diseases
in a lot of ways we are talking about
again extracting
meaningful signal from the data
so that it can be made available to
decision makers that can
look at the data in an intuitive way so
they have to be presented with that data
in an intuitive way
but also they have to be trained to be
able to ask
questions research questions based on
the data that they see
and lead to important research
topics that can be addressed effectively
in the lab in the research world
and by translational industry which
means
pharmaceutical and biotechnology
industry as well as the clinicians
that can actually take some finding in
the
in that research realm and translate it
to practice
so the other topic that we mentioned are
non-infectious diseases and
non-infectious diseases a good example
for us to start with
where molecular information and
sequencing information
plays a huge role is cancer and as we
all know
cancer is a growing concern we're much
more informed about cancer and what's
obvious today about cancer is that
there's a huge difference between types
of cancer
between the people that are affected
with different types of cancer
and the drivers of cancer
in the whole population around the world
and one of the clear signs is that
we know now that the cancer is
associated with aging
a lot of cancers are affecting older
people and so
as they become more risk
susceptible we need to understand how do
we
prevent and how do we treat this cancer
more effectively
and one of the things that is very
important in this is the ability to
identify cancer onset and stratify
patients according to risk according to
outcomes and make sure that we
incorporate this information in the
treatment plan
and one of those is to identify markers
of cancer risk
so before we go on i have a few
questions
based on what we just discussed today so
what do you think
are some examples of omnics data
that can help us study these conditions
including infectious diseases and cancer
what is an example of omics data
that is used in such research so if you
think about
different types of omics data maybe
you're familiar with different types of
omics data
you can write it out in the chat or if
you would like to unmute yourself and
say it
that is also fine so what is an example
of onyx data
okay so saran is mentioning metabolomics
dr sudha transcriptomics anushka jain is
also
saying transcriptomics okay excellent
ngs ngs can be used to
generate multiple types of omics data
okay dr sudhi is saying genomics
metabolomics okay gwas is a method of
analysis that's good
metabolomics okay anyone else
what other so we mentioned
transcriptomics and metabolomics and
genomics three
any other types of omics data just based
on what we discussed already
epigenomics okay so that's four what
else
proteomics five lipidomic six
metagenomics okay excellent
excellent i i think we we covered a lot
of epigenomics excellent
okay what kind of information can we
learn from
transcriptomic data okay so let's take
one of these
what kind of information can we learn
from transcriptomic data so there's
okay excellent gene expression okay so
what
gene expression is the information that
we extract from transcriptomic data
excellent
what are some of the challenges with
analysis of omics data
okay integration so fernanda fernando is
saying integration
zara is saying snips so snips i i'm
assuming you're referring to
what kind of information that is true we
can extract
the dominant snips from transcriptomic
data but more likely you're speaking
about genomic
data but what are some challenges with
analysis of omix data so fernando
already mentioned integration
that's an excellent challenge right how
do we take these
different types of sequences and we
extract
genomic data transcriptomic data and all
kinds of other data and
integrate them to understand what's
really going on okay what
what else what else do you think are
some of the challenges
and danilo is also mentioning isoforms
long non-coding rnas micrornas okay
excellent danilo thank you
so what are some of the challenges with
analysis of vomiting state
all right thank you fernando saying
computational requirements right this is
big data now that we have thousands of
patients
and each patient is generating some
genomic
transcriptomic metagenomic data now we
run into a problem of computational
resources
okay what additional challenges are
there
for okay data management exactly i've
analyzed this
i've analyzed that i have some tables
where did they come from how did i
generate them right
all of the data management questions
come to mind
okay great thank you everyone for your
questions last challenge
okay this is not for today
advances in next generation sequencing
so we talked about
omix data and a lot of the omics data is
coming from a very specific type of a
technology so
once it was discovered that the dna
encodes for genes that are then
transcribed into rna
that are then translated into protein we
now know that
next generation sequencing represents an
excellent opportunity
to study these molecular mechanisms of
regulation
that lead to specific phenotypes
and ultimately we even mentioned here
proteomics lipidonics
metabolomics all of these are functional
enzymes and molecules
and proteins that define the phenotype
but
whatever is encoded in the dna and the
way that it is
translated into proteins and all of
these elements
that is the machinery that we can study
to
understand what is really going on and
the unique part
about next generation sequencing is that
the cost
of next generation sequencing has been
dropping very steadily over time so
if you think back to 2001
we started from a hundred million
dollars for the full genome to sequence
the full genome and
16 years later in 2017 for the first
time
the price of the genome the whole genome
sequence was
just around 1 000 and so because of that
not only is this data informative it can
give us
insights into what's going on but it is
also accessible
and affordable and it is approaching
that threshold
that makes it comparable to some of the
other tests that are being done
in the clinic already and we've been
using them for a long time
and so to really understand that we can
look at the history of genomic data
which started in the 1950s when the
double helix structure was uh understood
and then very rapidly if you think up
until 2018
we've already had thousands of genomes
that have been sequenced for hundreds of
thousands of patients around the world
and so as you can see the price
the reduction in price led to an
explosion
of omics data that is now available
in research for companies in
biotechnology and pharmaceutical
industry
as well as in the clinic and so
to talk a little bit about the different
types of omics data we can mention that
there are many different types of omics
data that we can extract
based on sequencing and to understand
the relationship between
genotype or what is found in the
sequence and the phenotype
the first one is phenomics we know that
cells
function and look very differently
tissues they form different tissues
if you take a look at the morphology of
a cell it can tell you
that there's a huge difference in the
way that it functions between let's say
liver and blood right i mean think about
it one is a
solid tissue and one is a liquid
one performs one function another one
performs another function so obviously
that dna that contains information on
how to make those cells
includes all kinds of recipes that we
can study
and understand what is the potential of
all of these genes
to perform different types of functions
but ultimately
because of the phenotype differences we
know that not all of these genes are
equally activated and so we have to go
beyond just what's
encoded in the dna and we have to look
at how is that dna
regulated and so this is a growing area
of
research since about 2009 2010
there has been a tremendous interest in
epigenomic
data because it reveals epigenetic
regulation
how do these genes become more
accessible how
do they change from one isoform
to another isoform and so that
regulation
is called epigenomics that data like
chrome immunoprecipitation like whole
genome bisulfite sequencing
and many others microrna etc can really
reveal that
mechanism of regulation and then finally
we have transcriptomic data
which allows us to understand what has
actually been transcribed from the
messenger rna
and how can we study the various
isoforms
and transcripts that are being present
in a sample
now ultimately what does this lead us to
this lead us
leads us to a change in the way a
clinician
can look at a condition so if you think
of this
iceberg as a condition a patient that
comes in and says
my head hurts or i have a lump and so on
top
on the surface what we know is that
there's some clinical
data that might be available but beneath
the surface
there are these layers of onyx data
that can reveal the molecular properties
driving this top of the iceberg clinical
phenotype that the patients are
describing or that we can capture with
tests like blood tests and
imaging and and other types of
traditional
forms of generating clinical data now
what's underneath the tip of the iceberg
underneath the tip of the iceberg we
have the transcription
the translation and the result of that
translation
at as the protein and so what we know
now is that
we can take a look at specific proteins
that are critical for us to identify
patients that will respond
to certain therapies like the her2
protein
that help us categorize specific
patients into subgroups and understand a
lot better
why certain patients have different
responses to treatment or have different
prediction
or different anticipation of recovery
and remission so one of the examples for
these
is the evolution of breast cancer
classification so we know that
breast cancer is actually a complex
disease
includes many different tissues in the
breast
that are affected and they also have
different properties they grow at
different rates they have different
success at treatment
and so when we think about breast cancer
classification
we now can separate breast cancers into
multiple
subtypes of the actual disease based on
protein expression based on gene
expression based on different types of
risks found in the
genome and different types of mutations
that are found in the genome
and so one of the ways that we will use
this example
is to really look for how does the
prognosis
response to treatment stratification of
patients drug
purposing diagnosis target discovery and
risk prediction are all
components of precision medicine that we
are all anticipating and so
here's a glimpse of how we can study
cancer using these kinds of technologies
we can look at
understanding of risk early on so the
earlier
the better we can address the problem
that we are
anticipating we can also look at
likelihood of response to treatment
we can look at different types of drug
safety parameters better and so we can
optimize the treatment prevention
and prognosis ultimately for
patients and hopefully make sure that
this disease
is bringing lower mortality in a longer
healthier lifespan for patients
but at the core of this problem is the
integration of data
so at the core of this we need to
understand how
all of these pieces of data
bioinformatics chemo informatics
clinical data how do all of them tie
together to provide us
with a better sense of diagnostics and
therapeutics
and the problem is that this is really
creating a gap
and a gap in understanding as well as
a gap in industries that are trying to
address this gap and so the way that i
think that
this data gap is
disrupting industries and why
there is a growing need in people like
yourselves that are learning
bioinformatics and that are learning
translational bioinformatics
is because all of these industries which
are huge industries
have to adapt to this new uh status
which is
that everything is data driven and the
data is becoming more complex
and so as we think about this we really
should turn
to how does this information coming from
research
get translated to actual useful
information that and how is its
information being used
and so i think what we will do in this
program is we will start thinking about
how
experiments that are performed in the
lab with tissue culture
and cell lines how can they inform
the understanding of cancer and
a systems biology that we can study in
patient-derived genograph models and
animal models
how do these insights can get translated
to actual practical applications that
are applicable to patients
in clinical trials where we can test
drug responses
and improve the outcomes as well as to
the clinic
and one of the primary ways that this is
being done
is actually not even in the practice
realm
but first of all it is in the realm of
design and the design has to do with
data driven instead of a biological
hypothesis
based approach right so today the
information
is top down so someone that has studied
this
topic a particular type of cancer
particular type of a condition
is thinking and learning from
experiments and accumulates this
knowledge
and then designs experiments based on
their understanding and that is
hypothesis
based we take a textbook approach we
identify some important critical portion
and we design an experiment to validate
on the flip side of that of that is the
big data approach and the big data
approach is really saying
i have all of these accessible data sets
i can sample them
and sequence them and understand what is
going on
to start asking the questions
how do i address a particular variation
that i have found
or how does this affect patients that i
know of and so that is really what this
program is going to be all about
how do we change our thinking to a
data-driven approach
to the research data sets that are
available online
linking them to clinical information
that we can also find online
and that link helping us to think of
a big data approach to different types
of conditions and diseases and patients
that could ultimately benefit from
better treatment
earlier prediction and better prognosis
of outcomes
now i want to explain exactly
how can you benefit the most from
joining the program
by identifying specific steps that you
need to take
from this session up until the next
session
to get access to everything that you
will need to
practice the technical and the hands-on
activities that we will do
and to learn all of the material and so
to talk about that
i want to ask uh sonalika
to again talk us walk us through
how we can get access to all of the
resources that are needed
thank you so much helia let me share my
screen
yes so first of all i would want you
all to sign up on the portal learn dot
omits logic
i will be sharing the link with you all
if you all have signed up then just
let me walk you through how to update
your profile
and things ahead but if you have not
let's
give you two minutes to please sign up
this is the link
learn.amislogic.com i would want you
all to please sign up here you can sign
up either by creating your mail id and a
password for yourself or
also you can sign up via your social but
i would recommend you sign up creating a
password for yourself
and while others are signing up
i would want to take few of the things
those who have already signed up
please login to your profile and
i would want to know in the chat box if
you have signed up by
either sending a one or a yes so that i
know who all have completed their sign
up
so um so if you could please go to the
main page and just show from the
beginning
once people get on the portal how do
they actually take the steps to
make sure that they're registered thank
you yes
thank you so you can sign up either by
your id
and create a password for yourself or
via social
and let me just show how you can do so
via social
thank you for letting me know that you
have signed up
and those who have not they can sign up
with me because that is what you would
be required to go further in the process
for the program
thank you everyone
and now as you all have signed up like i
see many yes
those who are signed up i would want you
to take
to go through the update uh to update
your profile
and while i'm guiding the ones who have
signed up to update their profile
others can sign up in the meanwhile yes
so those who have signed up i would want
them to update their profile
and also link in their social accounts
linking in the social accounts would
help us
feature you all with your progress on
our social sites and also
uh we have a lot many recruiters so
uh seeing your progress we could
also take your profile ahead
and highlight them in front of the
recruiters that would be a great help to
you as well
and please ensure that as a part of the
program you are a part of the
bioinformatics for
precision medicine program you must see
a badge
of precision medicine here on your
profile this is for those who have
already registered and are a part of the
program
and please ensure that you have a
starter subscription
accessed with your account if yes and
please send a yes
anushka gerald i can see you have said
yes as well please check this and please
let me know
that uh please ensure you have a starter
batch and also you have the bash for the
program and also update your profile
picture and link in the
social once your profile is updated and
you
can see your activity uh on the
profile itself and also you would be
able to get these certificates
once you complete the given number of
assignments for the program
and also to go ahead with the project so
we would also take you further
to complete your project and upload it
in the later part of the
session but this is where you can just
look at your activity and get the
certificates as well and also look at
the courses and the programs that you
all
have covered so if you all have
completed your sign up
sahara says no batches only starter
subscription
okay zara i'll look into it and zahara
uh are you enrolled for the precision
medicine program
i'm sorry we have not received our
enrollment yet
so if you have then please mail me at
marketing at the rate pine dot bio so
that i cross check i should not be
missing out on any of the enrollments
i believe now everyone has completed
their sign up and if not then i'll share
the link again and you can do so
uh meanwhile or maybe later
now this is the program page with which
you have to
keep a check on and just share the
program page link
this is the program page by which you
have to register yourself
now if you hover over the program page
we have mentioned all the session
details in the page itself which has the
calendar
so you would be you would stay updated
with all the dates
of the session and also the session
details on which day what session would
be covered
and on the program page in the session
details itself you would have the
zoom link here and also the recording of
the session would be
uh published on the program page after
each session is over so let's say after
this session the first session
i would be uploading the recording of
the first session on the program page so
that you can go through the recording
if you miss out something and then take
your doubts right
and all those who have enrolled that
already a part of the program page so
please make it sure that by tomorrow you
can see the
recording of the session and
those who have not yet completed their
registration process
and would want to proceed further with
the registration on the same program
page they would get the option of the
levels beginner intermediate and
advanced now these levels we have
segregated on the basis of the
provisions provided you can just go
through all the provisions which would
be
provided as a part of the program for
these three different
levels and those who are a part of an
intermediate and advanced
level they would get to uh do a research
project
under our mentor and they can uh
further we would be guiding them further
for how their research project
has to be uh covered ahead and how they
have to
uh like go on from finding a data set
and then working on it doing the
analysis and then finally
uh publishing their work so we'll take
them through everything
towards the uh mirror and those who are
a part of intimidate and the advanced
levels and
as a part of the program you would also
get the access
to a lot of asynchronous course material
on the portal
and the courses to which the access
would be given as a part of the program
are mentioned here on the program page
and the certificate which would be uh
given for the program is
mentioned here as shown here as well and
this is what the format of the
certificate looks like
and as a part of the program uh you
would also get the access to the tea by
info server on which different sorts of
pipelines would be carried out and the
analysis would be done uh our mentors
would be taking you through
uh the pipelines as well and how you
have to
uh go ahead with each and every analysis
now those who have enrolled for them it
is
to know that your login credentials for
the
learn portal and the server would be the
same that is you
you must be able to login with your same
id and
password as that of learn on the tea by
info server
as well and if you face any of the
issues then do let us know
we'll have a look and this is the
detailed syllabus
because i know you all must be uh
excited to know about the
syllabus topics would be for each and
every session
so this is the detailed syllabus page
i'll share the link of the syllabus page
as well
and you can go through all of the
associated online resources which you
will get as a part of
each and every session too and to your
knowledge we are also there on linkedin
and facebook i would want you to be a
part of our linkedin and facebook page
so that you stay updated with all the
upcoming
uh other opportunities as well and also
stay
updated uh with who is doing the best
like i told you that we would be
featuring your profiles with the
performance
on our pages and uh we are there on
linkedin by the name of omixlogic
i'll share the link again and on
facebook we are there by the name of
pine biotech
and uh i'll just take a second more we
are
at present live on youtube so if you
would want to
go back and uh look at some of the uh
things which india mentioned you can go
to the link and watch the recording
over to you thank you thank you very
much
so i am going to show
once you are logged in so again for
those of you that
have completed your registration when
you go to the program link in sonarika
if you could again post the program
page on the program page you will find
the information that is already
relevant to what we are doing today so
right here you will see
the zoom link for example for our next
session
you will find the zoom link here once we
approach july 8th
and after today's session is over and
after you are done with
today's session you can click on
complete session
by marking this session as complete you
will start getting
points towards your certificate so you
can now see that i have
one out of 10 sessions complete and
as you go through these you will also
see for the completed ones that we have
already done instead of the zoom
after the session is over this will
become a video now as soon as i
mentioned here you have
the different resources and down at the
bottom we also have a slack channel
so if you have joined you can go to
ask the question and this should open up
slack if you already have an
account you should be able to open slack
directly
just like i'm doing right now and if you
don't have an account on slack it's a
free account
and you get to join our community of all
of the participants
so here you can see that all of you that
have joined
you should be a part of this slack
channel now on the slack channel
we will post important information about
practical assignments if you have any
questions you can ask them there
we will be posting the recorded sessions
and all of the needed information
in a timely way will be updated right
here
so again this is just a way for you to
be connected to all of the different
resources
and also you will find here a way to
book a meeting with us or ask questions
and also see your certificate but all of
this is
around your personal profile so really
as i mentioned
try to complete this profile as soon as
possible
okay so let me now go and talk a little
bit about
why this program is going to be focused
on data and how we're going to address
this problem
so the three things that our program is
going to provide you with
are the tools the skills and the
ideas about how to apply these tools and
data sets to different types of
challenges
and ultimately we're going to provide
you with a number of examples
of how you can take cellular omics data
understand the challenge in the
integration
and then try to understand the
relationship between clinical and
phenotypic data
with the different levels of omics data
that
we will describe in detail including
genomic data transcriptomic data
metagenomic data and others and as you
can imagine the obvious challenge with
this is that you are going to be
faced with many different technical
challenges that
are going to be difficult for those of
you that do not come from an engineering
background so here i would like to ask
you a question
about your background okay
so i know that we have participants with
different degrees so you could be a high
school student or a bachelor student or
a master's student or maybe a phd
or faculty so if you could please post
in the chat box right now
what is your level of education your
current level of education
high school bachelor's degree master's
degree
phd or if you are a faculty
okay excellent thank you phd
masters phd faculty masters in
biotechnology faculty
master's in computer science excellent
master's in biochemistry
master's in biochemistry
okay i'll just give it a couple more
minutes phd
masters in technology and bioinformatics
okay
excellent okay so
one of the challenges in bioinformatics
is that there are a lot of methods
algorithmic methods
there are a lot of different types of
data and there are also a lot of things
that are not well defined so their
data wrangling data visualization
different types of
approaches to scripting that require
everyone to be
aware of how to just deal with data
what's called beta literacy
and i think on the flip side on the
engineering side
what is oftentimes not clear to people
coming from an engineering background
is how do these methods of
computer software essentially address
the problems
in biology and so this program
is really designed to bring those two
together
to take the biological terminology and
the computer science slash engineering
aspects of bioinformatics and
bring them closer together and to do
that
we want to make sure that everyone is
familiar
with some of the basic ideas
about biological background
as well as the basics of computational
and data science
skills that you need to have and to do
that
we have designed a number of courses
that you should start with
so let me share some of those with you
okay so if you go to the courses tab
you will find here some important
coursework
that you can start with as you are
getting started with this program or any
other program that we have
for those of you coming from an
engineering background
we recommend a course called bytes and
molecules
it will introduce you to some of the
basic terminology
and give you a sense of what is a
mutation what is gene expression
how do we use this information to answer
biological questions
for those of you that are not familiar
with bioinformatics
we recommend to get started with this
course called introduction to
bioinformatics
and that will give you some perspective
on the applications of bioinformatics
in general like the introduction to big
data bioinformatics how do we start
thinking with this
data-driven instead of a
hypothesis-driven research
how is bioinformatics used in healthcare
and
biomedical research and then also what
is translational bioinformatics so
if you have just registered recently or
you
are now registering
please make sure that you start with
these courses
okay so again you create a profile and
once you create a profile this is a free
course so anyone can take this
and once you have completed this course
again you can click always on your name
right here
and you can go to the course tab to see
your progress
with different courses so by next time
that we meet
please make sure that you have completed
introduction to bioinformatics
and bytes and molecules so these are
going to be important courses for you to
complete
so that we can all continue and move
forward
now the other side of things is that you
will need
access to our big data analysis platform
okay so let me briefly explain how it
works
and what we will do using a
short example okay please go to this
link server.tbio.info
for those of you that registered today
you probably don't have your access
yet for those of you that have
registered previously
starting from yesterday you should be
able to use your
uh omixlogic login details your email
and your password
to be able to get in so please let me
know once you're logged in
you should be able to see your name
right here your email address right here
under your profile okay put number one
if you can log in or no so
number one or yes if you can log in
number two or no
if you cannot log in
okay so dr sudha again given that you
have created
an account on omixlogic not today
so if you just created your account
today you still don't have access
it takes up to 24 hours for your profile
to be created on the big data analysis
platform but for those of you that have
registered a while ago yesterday or
before that
you should already have your login okay
so anjali pravin dr
sudha i am assuming you just registered
today correct
yes so if you just registered today you
will not have access but
you can still follow along and then
tomorrow you can replicate the same
steps so your free account will come
with this information
so let me briefly introduce you to what
we can do
on this portal and to do that i will
take an example project
that we will go through in our
discussions
okay so uh gerald when did you
sign up okay
so gerald if you can try and
uh sonalika maybe you could help uh
gerald
uh he should have his account set up
already
if he doesn't maybe dr harpreet can help
him okay so once you're in
you will see that this is a big data
analysis environment
that you can use to try out a number of
different approaches
to analysis of big data
and instead of going into the main
section what we will do is we will
open it up as a drop down and we will
take
at this cell line project the first
project right here
so once you're inside you will see that
this
is a graph of different methods each box
here represents
an algorithm and this algorithm has a
logical
purpose that logical purpose is stated
in the box above
so when we take raw sequencing data we
would like to
clean this data we would then like to
map it on the genome
make sure that we are capturing the
isoforms and recording them in the gtf
file
mapping this information on transcript
so we know transcript
abundance by quantifying expression
levels
and then performing differential gene
expression or even just preparing our
table of expression for downstream
analysis
and so to illustrate how you can go from
raw data
to structured data i will just
demonstrate a brief step-by-step process
where we start we clean up the data
with traumatic and pcr clean
we then can map onto the genome
isoform construction using cufflinks
add that information to the gtf file
using gtf processing
mapping on transcripts using bowtie2t
preparing an rsm gene expression table
that looks like this
and then we can actually click on end
to see the output files and so here you
will see a number
of different outputs so in a similar way
what we will do in this program is we
will go through genomic data
transcriptomic data metagenomic data and
introduce you to some of the common
tools and methods that you need to
understand
and place them in the right position in
the bioinformatics pipeline
to get meaningful results does anyone
have any questions about this before i
go on
okay the second thing that you will be
introduced to
are some data repositories
so we will not just take data sets that
we give you but we will actually
introduce you to repositories where you
can find
data independently does anyone here
have any sense of where to find data
about cancer omics data about cancer
i'll give you a hint one of the
repositories is right there on the
screen
all right excellent c bio portal tcga
excellent so what is tcga
what kind of data do we have on tcga
leena
okay cancer genome atlas so doctor
okay what kind of data do we actually
have on tcga
okay the answer is we have patient data
so there are
a number of different tumors that
exactly cancer genomic data cancer
transcriptomic data so it's multi-omics
data
that has been integrated so we can
easily search and
find different types of data but beyond
that there are also data sets
on ncbi for example national center for
biotechnology information
so we will also go through some research
papers
that describe applications of cancer
cell line
and patient-derived xenograft models or
animal models
that we can use to find interesting
insights like biomarkers
that have a computational component to
them and allow us to predict
outcomes for different types of
treatment response so we will take a
look at some of those data sets
in the tcga data sets we will take a
look at the association between clinical
information
and genomic information as well as other
other types of omics
and ultimately we will also take a look
at some infectious disease research
challenges where we can identify
important
information about infectious diseases
and the pathogens that cause them as
well as the immune responses so
as a result you will find important
information on how to perform standard
analysis
like phylogenetic analysis gene
expression
composition analysis of
alignment and variant calling insights
into structural biology
and how to integrate all of these data
sets so we will talk about those and
what i recommend to get started is to
start looking
at some of the important project
examples that we will be using
throughout this program okay where do
you find them
again you go to courses and you can
start looking through some of the
examples right here for example
tcga liver cancer project on precision
oncology
or covenanting origin and pathogenesis
of source code 2.
so if you have an interest in cancer
type data
or in infectious diseases you can find
some project examples
okay so finally i want to mention again
that
all of this information is going to go
towards
your own individual progress so even
though this is a program it brings you
together as a group
the objective is for you to grow
personally and we hope that you will be
able to develop an independent project
so how do you go from learning about
these skills
and trying out different examples to
actually
developing an independent project as
sonic already mentioned
we have a system designed to help you
go from learning to then application
and that will be focused on the aspect
of developing
a bioinformatics project so we hope that
this program will help you start
conceive of a project and then start
thinking about how do you actually
conduct the analysis that you have
planned
so if you're a phd you're already
working in some
kind of a project where you have omix
data you want to integrate it this is
not just going to be learning about
bioinformatics this is going to be
let's do bioinformatics let's get this
done and let's apply these tools
to a data set of your own and for that
you
need to have the advanced account
and advanced registration for the
program or you can participate in the
research fellowship program
as a additional level to your
subscription with this program
and then pursue your project
independently so
before we leave i want to leave you
with this slide where you will find
important courses that you can start
with introduction to bioinformatics
and bytes and molecules as well as
some information about how to get
started
with bioinformatics in python and in r
and how to design a bioinformatics
research project so if you're coming
from a life science background
how do you actually think about
selecting a topic finding that data set
and then applying what you learn in this
program to design
an independent bioinformatics research
program and once you start making
progress
you will see that on this page you have
some simple steps
for you to get to a level where you can
conduct a project independently
with our support and then publish it on
here
as a featured project and just to give
you a sense of what that looks like if
you scroll all the way to the bottom of
this page
you will find here a couple of examples
glioblastoma
covid19 drug repurposing and lymphocytic
leukemia
will give you a good sense of what you
can come out with
as you develop these project ideas
during this program
so that's all we wanted to share in
terms of today's session
so malik i will pass it on back to you
if you have anything to add before we
close and if
anyone has any questions that i can
answer please put them in the chat
and we'll be happy to see you again next
time
thank you so much ilya and thank you so
much everyone so listen
uh for listening so patiently so today
we discussed about the role of
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and in the next sessions we would be
going through the practical aspects and
also we'll take you through the project
samples
and go forward with carrying out the
analysis
and also we would be talking about next
generation sequencing and big data
analysis
and then we would go towards discussing
the applications for
infectious diseases that would be viral
and bacterial infections
and then also discuss about the armies
data the role of homicides data
in cancer research be it genomics
transcriptomics or epigenetics
and we would be waiting for you all
to interact with in the next sessions
thank you for joining today
and so yes so we have few questions
thank you easier for answering
also there was one question i think it
went and answered let me take that
and um you can ask the questions if you
have any sort of in the chat box right
now
we can answer them for you
so just about the software i want to
clarify
uh if you are going to participate in
all of the sessions
in future sessions you will require some
software like
integrative genome browser
you will be able to browse
vcf files and see how we can identify
mutations that are present in some
samples so we will have some
of that software that is described in
the projects that we will discuss
and uh for those of you that are wanting
to participate in a project with an
intermediate enrollment you can
but the intermediate enrollment does not
give you enough time
so the training that will come first
will prepare you to design a project
proposal but it will not give you enough
time to actually complete your project
and so we recommend having the advanced
subscription or if you already have an
intermediate enrollment
also consider joining the research
fellowship program which will give you
three to six months to actually complete
your project
yes thank you so much
and uh also i was getting the questions
from
lbrn participants so bioinformatics for
precision medicine
is not a program for the lbrn uh
it is not under the programs under lbrn
so if you would want to uh proceed your
application for by information precision
medicine program
i'll just mail you all the details
and yes for those of you from lbrn that
want to participate in this program in
addition to other programs that you are
involved in we can definitely take your
information
and share it with the lbrn leadership to
see if they are going to provide some
kind of scholarship for you
but we do need to have your details for
that and we need to know for sure that
you are interested
and i know the praveen did you want to
ask something i'm sorry i think you were
interrupted
okay okay no no
okay okay no problem
um nearby if you completed a
master's in biotechnology you want to
learn bioinfo without any pay program
yes you don't have to pay you can learn
a lot about bioinformatics on your own
for free there are many resources online
we provide some of the free
resources like introduction to
bioinformatics so please do take the
course introduction to bioinformatics
no cost completely free just make a
profile nearby
and start learning
okay excellent thank you everyone and
glad that all of you joined
and looking forward to seeing you again
next time
thank you so much everyone i'm just
dropping my mail id if you have any of
the dolls you
you can ask me it's marketing at the
rate fine dot
bio or you can also find me at uh mohit
anthony pine dot bio
or marketing at the rate or misogyny.com
uh when a yes i'll share the i've added
you
to uh to the slack channel already so
please check your
mail id you would get the email from uh
the invitation for the slack channel
thank you just
thank you everyone for joining we are
looking forward